scp-106 also known as the old man is a
ketter-class humanoid entity with the
appearance of an elderly decomposing
individual it exhibits a corrosion
effect on all solid matter it touches
causing a physical breakdown in
materials within seconds the corrosion
continues for six hours and is
particularly harmful to living tissues
scp-106 is capable of passing through
solid matter and can enter a pocket
Dimension exiting at any connected Point
scp-106 remains motionless for days
while waiting for prey it incapacitates
victims by damaging organs muscles or
tendons before dragging them into its
pocket Dimension the means by which a
victim can escape this pocket Dimension
remains unknown observations of complex
structures have shown that scp-106 can
be confused resulting in a delay in
entering or exiting structures research
on scp-106 is ongoing to better
understand Its Behavior reduce potential
casualties and improve containment
measures